hi I'm Troy and belisario and these are
your burning questions let's do this
which project for yours would Yuri watch
right now if you had to pour it I'd
probably rewatch pretty little liars
just so like with like a drinking game
like I'd make my friends come over and
we'd watch it and honestly like kind of
make fun of me a little bit and then get
drunk okay PLL the perfections revealed
that Spencer and Toby eloped after the
ending of PLL that's sweet where do you
think they elope to and did you know
about that or did you learn about it
right now
Keagan once texted me and was like doo
doo doo doo doo
Marlene is freaking out on Twitter right
now what's happening what's happening
his way after the show ended and I was
like what's it what's going on and I
looked on Twitter and Marlene started
writing she wrote a Twitter thread that
was like Spencer and Toby elope Spencer
and Toby did this she comes home and
issues essentially like writing episodes
of PLL but on Twitter I think the fans
were super pissed at the ending of pol
which I wasn't I was really happy with
it because I always thought they would
make it in the end but they the fans had
to have them together and so they eloped
and where did they elope I don't know
they looked in Pennsylvania where the
show was set do you have any stories
from filming where'd you go Bernadette
with Kate Blanchet yes but she's the
most incredible person of all time and
she can fake birth which I can't and she
was kind enough to try and teach me was
an absolute disaster
something that Kay planchet can't do is
teach me how to park who was your first
celebrity crush Leonardo DiCaprio done
did you know billboard dad is on Hulu
now I didn't when's the last time you
rewatched that probably not since I was
really little and it just made it can
you explain where your twitter or
instagram handle came a Instagram handle
asleep in the garden came from one of my
favorite singer songwriters in the world
is this guy named Conor Oberst who's in
the band bright eyes and he has a song
called June on the west coast where that
one of the lyrics is if it's June we'll
sleep out in the garden and
when I created it that was what I
thought was cool and it still is what's
the biggest thing you've learned about
yourself from being a mom that I'm not
the most important thing ever okay if
you were going on a trip to find
yourself where would you go either back
to Iceland cuz I loved being there and I
would love like being alone in that
wilderness or maybe Morocco because I've
always wanted to go there I might
actually go to Antarctica that was
pretty amazing to do research for how
long did you know you were a I'm pretty
little liars before it was revealed for
years it's a long time to give a secret
but I'm good at it
what's a role people should be surprised
to find out you auditioned for well I
mean when I was really when I was
younger I auditioned to be in white or
Lander to be the girl in white or Lander
and I got pretty close on that I broke
my heart when I didn't get it cuz I
loved that movie so much I still love
that movie how did you prepare your
accent to play Alex Drake I worked with
a vocal coach and I studied episodes of
The Only Way Is Essex what was the
inspiration behind the short film we are
here what was it like writing it with
Patrick and then being directed by him
horrible no I'm kidding the inspiration
behind we are here is that Patrick's
sister Meredith
who's an absolutely incredible human
being and I look up to her a lot she
lives in a a beautiful part of the world
known as Haida Gwaii
and Patrick and I had the great fortune
to go up there and visit her quite a lot
we wanted to write a story about a man
and a woman coming to terms with the end
of our society so we wanted to write a
little bit of an apology extort from the
point of view of the world ending but
really from it beginning again so we
imagined it like a reverse Adam and Eve
it was a blast writing it with Patrick
sometimes like pulling teeth
but he knew what he wanted to he knew
what he wanted the story to be so it's
happy to facilitate that and then being
directed by him is just it's a total
dream because I trust him he knows me in
and out so he can tell when I'm
bullshitting and he would tell me if he
didn't like something and I just knew
that he was always gonna make me have my
best performance which PLL cast members
do you still keep in touch with mostly
with Shae and then also a little bit
with Ashley hook who do you relate to
more Becky and where'd you go Bernadette
or Spencer Hastings
I probably actually relate to Becky more
just because I love the idea of getting
to commit yourself to your passion and
follow it through and then Spencer I
relate to more on a personality level
like her obsessive-compulsive qualities
her sort of like addictive and like um
controlling qualities her perfectionist
qualities but her life choices and being
blackmailed I don't relate to which do
you prefer acting in movies or TV shows
and why depends on the movie or the TV
show and why you can guess what TV shows
are you currently obsessed with yuphoria
oh yeah yeah you're killing me Sam
Levenson you're killing me you for yeah
I'm really excited that succession is
back on Handmaid's Tale always Oh
fleabag Phoebe can we please leave AXYZ
in two was perfect television we can end
it there perfect television if you could
star in any other adaptation of a book
you've read what would it be there are
so many but I would probably say cuz I
think it's coming out soon and I'm
really excited Emily sent mando a
Canadian writer wrote
station 11 which is an incredible book
if you haven't read it it's finally
being made into a television series and
I just couldn't be more excited I think
it's wonderful they're not burning
anymore we've answered them I hope you
feel a lot cooler and go see where'd you
go Bernadette on August 16 bye guys
thank you so much for having me
[Music]